a miles de kilómetros en medio del
océano índico la remota isla de la
reunión puede haber encontrado la
solución para el futuro del islam en la
francia continental los llamados a las
plegarias del viernes se resuenan por la
ciudad de sant tenis mientras los fieles
se reúnen dentro de la mezquita islámica
de nor que construida en el siglo 19 con
los colores de la bandera francesa en
sus vitrales las plegarias se llevan a
cabo en árabe y en francés y la mezquita
es administrada por un comité elegido
por tres años mientras que los imanes no
son tan solo empleados un gran cambio
frente a la francia continental donde
muchos imanes se encargan de dirigir las
mezquitas lo único que dirigimos es el
culto religioso no tenemos nada que ver
con el trabajo administrativo de eso se
encarga un comité de los imanes los
imanes sólo se encargan de la oración
los imanes son graduados del instituto
de teología islámica
este centro entrena 60 estudiantes al
tiempo algunos de los cuales se irán a
predicar a la francia continental aquí
aprenden árabe
del corán pero la educación cívica y la
historia francesa también hacen parte
del programa y así fue la coronación de
carlomagno
y los estudiantes están de acuerdo en
que el entrenamiento que siguen durante
4 a 7 años es absolutamente esencial
quiero convertirme en imán en la francia
metropolitana pero conocer el propio
contexto es importante debemos tener un
buen conocimiento de francés de su
historia
hay personas en la francia metropolitana
que no están transmitiendo de manera
correcta la religión y mané sin un
entrenamiento adecuado
entonces de cierta manera usted quiere
mejorar la calidad de la prédica decirlo
así es un poco pretencioso de mi parte
pero ser parte de ese esfuerzo si aquí
el objetivo final no sólo es entrenar
futuros imanes sino contextualizar las
escrituras coránicas en la sociedad
francesa a fawcett ap
francia es un país de cultura
judeo-cristiana debemos aceptar eso y
entenderlo reconocer esta realidad
podemos seguir practicando nuestra
religión con serenidad
el instituto depende por completo de las
donaciones las contribuciones
financieras también son cruciales para
la mezquita que tiene un presupuesto
anual de 1,3 millones de euros nuestro
presupuesto es financiado por las
tiendas que ven aquí también tenemos
otros activos inmobiliarios en la ciudad
de sandy meyer la mezquita es totalmente
autofinanciada a diferencia de algunos
lugares de culto en el territorio
continental que son mantenidos por
marruecos argelia o turquía la inversión
extranjera es impensable aquí cuando uno
depende de dinero externo quedan deudas
es posible que a uno le impongan algunas
visiones o estar forzado a adoptar
algunas orientaciones religiosas que no
corresponden al islam que practicamos
aquí
la ciudad de santa de anís también
alberga una de las pocas escuelas
islámicas privadas bajo contrato con el
estado la responsable educativa afirma
que el modelo ofrecido por los
musulmanes en la isla de la reunión
podría ser beneficioso para el
territorio continental
es cierto que aquí estamos mostrando lo
que la repubblica en la reunión sabe
hacer mejor sabemos que estamos siendo
observados entonces con orgullo
mostramos lo que hemos logrado aquí
un marco de trabajo estructurado y
coordinado que por ahora sigue siendo el
único en toda francia